and what are you so afraid of me
and just who are you
oh I've been dubbed many
names by many people
a ruler
a conqueror
he who remains
a jerk
but it's it's not as simple
as a name what is going on everybody
welcome back to the cosmic wonder I'm
Warren Thompson and Kang the Conqueror
is on his way and Ken could quite
possibly be the best big bad yet however
most people can't really see this yet
because Kang isn't exactly as well known
as Thanos was and we've only gotten a
little taste of him with he who remains
and although he who remains his entrance
into the MCU was iconic and that Loki
finale was insanely good we haven't
exactly gotten a taste of what Kang is
truly capable of and even as he who
remains said if you think that he was
evil just wait until you see his
variance if you think I'm
evil well this way
till you meet bye variance
that's the Gambit and you even saw in
the beginning he stated he was afraid of
himself his own variance Kang literally
created the TVA to keep his other
variants away remember the multiversal
war wasn't between a lot of different
people in a lot of different universes
it was only between the variants of king
and the armies that Kane commanded and
as we've seen in the trailers for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania this
came the Conqueror that we're going to
have to deal with in the MCU does indeed
have a huge Army and a huge base camp
setup in the middle of the quantum realm
so pretty soon in quantumania we're
going to get a taste of how powerful
smart and scary Kang truly is as a big
bad and I think that somewhere in this
Army one of the commanders of the army
working for Kang is going to be Ultron
and possibly even an Ultron Army as well
now keep in mind we actually saw this in
Multiverse of Madness but luckily in
that movie The Illuminati were the ones
who controlled the Ultron Bots but what
if in other universes Kang is the one
who controls them this would make an
already extremely powerful villain even
more powerful and I think that this
could be about to happen in the MCU as
we've gotten reports that Ultron is
going to be returning and I think that
it could be revealed that Ultron could
be a part of keng's Army in quantumania
which is only right around the corner
less than two months now and this could
quite possibly be one of the coolest
things to ever take place in the MCU so
do us a favor and let us know what you
think about this Theory after you watch
the video also big thank you to Elgato
for being a great partner this year
thank you for the Christmas package that
you sent me I love being a part of the
Elgato family and if you're a content
creator or looking to be one Elgato has
the perfect equipment for you to make
your studio awesome and to make
everything sound and look fantastic if
you're looking for their gear you can
check it out in the link down below so
how exactly would this work well first
things first keep in mind that the
quantum realm isn't really a universe
yes it is sort of another world however
it exists between and outside of time
and space so it is its own Universe in a
way but it exists outside of other
universes outside of time so there
really isn't a timeline for the quantum
realm So when you say Kang has an Army
in this universe it's not exactly
accurate because Kang actually took the
army that he has inside of the quantum
realm from other universes probably more
than one because that is the threat of
Kang one of the biggest threats of Kang
actually he can go to other universes at
different points of time way into the
future and gather Advanced items
including weapons and people and add
them to his army and bring them to the
quantum realm where his base camp is And
I stress the importance of this because
there have been reports that Ultron
could return however Ultron could return
in many different ways in many different
universes the Ultron that we saw in
Avengers Age of Ultron could indeed
return in our main MCU Universe however
I think that can is in control of a
different Ultron and possibly even more
than one and this actually comes down to
kind of a leak that we've heard for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania now for
quantumania you have probably seen and
heard that there are going to be
different variants of different
characters in that movie in fact the
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania showed us many different Ant-Man
variants one of which met a very bad
fate turned into string cheese much like
Mr Fantastic and Multiverse of Madness
but Ant-Man variants aren't the only
variants that we're going to see
According to some reports about what to
expect from the movie Not only will we
see Ant-Man variants but we'll see
variants of other characters that we
have seen before in the MCU however of
course since their variants they'll be
coming from different universes and
they're not exactly going to be good
we're going to see some characters who
are normally Heroes be villains and some
reports even go on to say that some of
these characters could be from previous
Avengers teams or have at least fought
with the Avengers now this is very
exciting in and of itself if it does
happen to be true and happen on screen
and if so I can't wait to see the
characters that they get however the
main point of this and what this tells
us is that Kang kind of recruited an
army from multiple different universes
and I think that Ultron could be one of
those peoples that he recruited Kang is
all about technology that's where he
gets all of his powers from he doesn't
actually have any natural Powers Kang is
actually from the future in fact he who
remains states that the variant of
himself that discovered the universes
were on top of each other was from the
31st Century that's a thousand years
ahead of us and the characters in the
MCU so the first Kang already had
advanced technology just by living in
the time that he was born in and from
there he created the first time machine
that he would use to go back in time
forward in time everywhere in time until
eventually he would figure out how to go
to other universes as well and this is
where it gets kind of cool because it
seems to me that he went to other
universes and gathered the best part and
the most powerful parts of each universe
and that does not only consist of
weapons and Technology but people as
well and if that's what king truly is
doing going to different universes and
timelines in order to get the most
technologically advanced things that
would benefit him in taking over every
single Universe the entire Multiverse I
would imagine that at some point in time
he would come across an Ultron Army and
Ultron himself and think to himself this
could be very useful for me if I
commanded this Army and I commanded all
Ultron I could essentially hack into
anything that I want to this means that
Kang could essentially wipe out all
technology of a single world and send
them back to the Dark Ages he could
knock out all of their technology all of
their weapon systems their defense
systems anything with Ultron he could
essentially take over the entire web in
a way Ultron really is kind of the
perfect weapon for Kang to harness so
Ultron being a part of Kang's Army does
make sense in fact the blue Army that we
see in quantumania the army that King
has I wouldn't be surprised if a lot of
it was made out of Ultron Bots now I
should also note that in the spirit of
Ultron returning the cosmic circus does
mention Ultron returning but in our
universe the Ultron from our universe
returning they state that they've heard
from a source that remnants of the old
Ultron still exist and in Age of Ultron
Tony Stark and vision did say that in
order to defeat Ultron they explained
that every form that Ultron has built
every trace of his presence on the net
had had to be destroyed or he could
return and to be fair we've seen a lot
of traces of him still left in
Spider-Man homecoming we see that the
dodc has an Ultron head in one division
we learned that sword has shifted their
focus to robotics nanotech Ai and
sentient weapons and even rebuilt a
vision body without the Mind Stone and
then of course recently in Black Panther
wakanda forever Queen raimonda stated
that AI will one day rise up and kill us
all which could all be hints that Ultron
is indeed returning however like I
mentioned I am pretty sure that Kang has
probably gathered an Ultron From Another
Universe and has somehow managed to take
control of that Ultron because Ultron
doesn't like to play nice with other
people he would be more than likely to
rebel against King however if King
hacked inside of him and took full
control of him that means that there's
not really a threat of Ultron anymore
the threat is Kang controlling Ultron
and essentially kind of becoming him if
he's able to use Ultron at will and do
whatever he wants he essentially is
Ultron or at least has all of his
abilities I for one would love to see
this happen this would be a crazy cool
Twist on top of I'm sure a lot of other
really cool twists we're going to see
with King the Conqueror but I think this
could make him so much more powerful in
the MCU not that he really needs it with
the ability to control time and jump
different universes but if we're looking
for an exceptional big bad one that is
better than we've ever seen before
better than Loki Ultron Thanos you name
it it would be really cool to see one
big bad control a previous Big Bad Plus
not to mention Kang is going to talk
about how he let Thanos do everything
that he did so they could show us just
how strong Kang is by saying that yeah
remember the previous big bads well
Ultron he now has full control over and
as far as Thanos goes well he let Thanos
do everything but if he wanted to step
in and say stop it and defeat Thanos he
probably could have and I wouldn't be
surprised if we actually see some
footage of Kang defeating Thanos in a
different Universe than our main MCU
just to truly show how strong Kang the
Conqueror really is but hey this is just
a theory about how Kang could be
controlling Ultron and how Ultron could
return possibly in Quantum Mania and
then of course in the Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars but let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below what do you think would this be
good or not don't forget to like the
video and of course subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the future
videos you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof